hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar
cancer on a chip the microfluidic 2d and
3d cell culture system
for studying cellular microenvironments
presented by dr vivek comments
i'm christy jewel of labyrinths and i'll
be moderating this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by
gibco at thermo fisher scientific
now let's get started
today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
in the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we apply for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
use that ask a question box and let us
know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present to you today's speaker dr
vivit common postdoctoral associate
florida international university
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr comment you
may now begin your presentation you for
the introduction
good morning my name is dr vivek karma
firstly
i like to thank chipko and thomas fisher
scientific
for giving me this platform to share my
work
i would also like to thank chelsea for
giving this opportunity to talk
about microfluidic 2d and 3d cell
culture systems for cancer research
to start with i would like to share some
background information
and geographical insights about my
education
workplace and academic career i was born
in city of pune also in an oxford of the
e8
located on the western indian state of
maharashtra the city is blessed with
vibrant rich culture and also
highest number of research organizations
in india
i did my graduation and post graduation
biotechnology from calvary college
and carried my doctoral work at average
research institute and received a phd
in 2018 after which i immediately joined
the group of dr shekhar bhansali at
florida international university
in the department of electrical
engineering
so to begin with here are the cancer
statistics obtained by world health
organization
which shows prevalence of cancer
throughout the globe
in the image it can be seen that
premature mortality rates are
significantly higher
and is the number one leading cause of
death in 48 countries which are
indicated by the blue color
is the second leading cause of that in
countries marked with light blue color
and countries with fourth and fifth
leading cause of death are marked in
orange and red color
it is expected that until 2020
there will be one 18 point 18.1 million
new cases
with 9.6 million deaths due to cancer
and therefore cancer research is one of
the major priorities in developed and
developing nations
so currently the major challenges faced
are early detection cancer prediction
new drug screening and post cancer
treatment
so to address this challenge the first
experimental step
starts from carrying out in vitro cell
culture assays
but there is a need to develop better
models to study cancer
as we all know that the magnitude of
variation which we receive
during performing in vitro to invigo
transitions
so we need better systems because to
study
cellular functions and behaviors in
dynamic condition which mimics in vivo
scenarios
understanding micro environment is
realistic way
and study various core and multiculture
systems
which would eventually bridge the gap
between in vitro and in vivo system
generating realistic data in primary
stages of investigation
so let us see how dynamic cellular micro
environment works
dynamic system is combination of
biochemical physical
and physiochemical factors which
constitute cells micro environment
as seen in the schematic cell
experiences blood flow
shear stress pressure drop stretching
interaction with physical barriers and
collectively imparting physical forces
on the cells
further there is concentration gradients
exchange of gases
there are chemical signaling molecules
and exothermic
cellular molecules which constitutes the
biochemical factors
and lastly physiochemical factors such
as temperature ph
collectively interact and affect the
cells and yet in such a dynamic system
cells are able to replicate and perform
its designated function
uh but in traditional dish space or
you know now conventional assays these
functions such as sensing replication
exchange of materials might be altered
as cells do not experience
a dynamic environment it is known that
cell
exchange morphologies when cells
i mean i'm sorry it is known that cell
changes morphologies when exposed to
substrate deformation
but cells in culture play do not
experience these forces and eventually
lose these properties
therefore studying dynamic system for
studying cellular microenvironment
without compromising natural properties
and behavior of the cells is crucial
so how can we study cell dynamic systems
and one of the one of the answers is
biofluidics
so what is microfluidics microfluidics
is study and manipulation of small
volumes of fluid
in channels and chamber with dimensions
of tens of microliters
microfluidic cell culture attempts to
develop devices and techniques for
culturing
maintaining analyzing and experimenting
cells in microscale volume
now using this microfluidic techniques
we can actually
we can actually make devices uh to carry
out 2d and 3d cell culture systems
in the following image shows a
microfluidic chip comprising of inlets
for media
a culture chamber in which cells can be
grown and
outlet for removal of spent media so
such chips can be used
to culture cancer cells for assessing
various different cellular activities
so now let us see what are the
differences between in vitro culture
and microfluidic cell culture system in
in vitro system the cell substrate is
transparent stiff and has low gas
permeability
while microbic systems the substrate is
soft
and is flexible and also has high gas
permeability
in mathematics system cells can be
handled and cultured
ranging from single to thousand cell
which is actually not possible in a
plate based assay
conventional culture is carried out in
flask dish and plates which require
larger volume as compared to
microfluidic devices
which can work with volumes as less as
60 nanoliters
also nutrients in traditional culture
are in great access and media needs
change after every 48
hours while in mathematics system media
turnover is faster and some reports
indicate more glucose consumption
one particular thing about microfluidic
cell culture is the proliferation rate
and in conventional assays the
proliferation
the rate is typically between 18 to 24
hours
but in microfluidic system there have
been reports where
it has been shown less as well as faster
proliferation rates of the cells
so how do we culture cells in
microfluidic systems
culturing cells and microbiotic devices
require a strong understanding of
certain fundamental principles spanning
disciplines such as physics chemistry
biology and engineering
so it's more of an interdisciplinary
kind of study
and there are certain criterias which
need to be followed firstly the
developed system should closely mimic
conditions
that exist in vivo and the person
handling should have
good command on cell culture techniques
to translate methods from macro to a
microscope
i mean to micro to macro scale and this
is usually the most challenging part
also another criteria is person should
have
a strong background in designing and
microfabrication techniques
so let us see what are the steps
involved in establishing a successful
microfluidic culture
so the first step obviously is the
fabrication of the device this is
typically carried out
by techniques such as photolithography
and soft lithography
after which you have to select the type
of cell which you are going to
investigate
so it can be cancelled non-cancerous
cells
and based on their properties such as
earlier and or non-earlier end
we might need to fabricate a different
or a new disk in a microfluidic check
then we need to perfuse media into the
chip which is usually
done using syringe pump or paraslatic
pumps
the chips are then monitored using
microscopic technique
we usually use light cell microscopy in
our lab
and at last the span meter is collected
which contains all the extracellular
components and dead cells
so let us see the first step which is
the fabrication process in
detail so microfabrication process is
divided into two parts one is
photolithography and another is soft
lithography so
as the name suggests photolithography
is a technique which uses uh which is
used to edge surface using light and
this is usually
a uv source basically in little in
photolithography we have a mask which is
nothing but a stencil on which the
design of the microphotic chip is edged
on a silicon software
substrate which is called the wafer a
layer of photoresist is coated
we in our lab we use su-8 for this after
which the mask is aligned on the
substrate and uv
is exposed once exposed for a definite
time the uv light passes to the stem
cell or the mask
and erodes the photoresist at the point
creating design
on the mask onto the substrate after
etching the final baking and development
is carried out
to obtain the substrate with the design
further pdms which is a
known polymer it's called polymethyl
philoxane
is added to the substrate and allowed to
cure once pdma solidifies
it is it is peeled off and the
replicated design
is uh and the design gets replicated on
pdms
in case of soft lithography the move is
first prepared
and then pdms is just added into the
mold and cured
the ems is a room temperature
vulcanizing rubber that solidifies the
mixed with curing agent
and this process can be accelerated by
applying heat so after turing
the pdms is beyond filled and we are
left with design pattern
on the pdms
further this is the process of
photolithography so as i explained
earlier
in the first step the silicon wafer is
removed from the clean room
it is kept on the spin coater in the
third step the photoresist such as suv
polymer is added
and it spin at desired rpm to achieve a
specific thickness
then it is pre-baked after this step the
mask is selected
step 6 and 7 is aligning of the mask
using a mask aligner
in step 8 uv is exposed and finally
in step 10 the mask the exposed surface
is washed
finally we have the desired geometry on
the wafer
now this acts as a mold and pdm is added
on the wafer
which is allowed to cure and the
microfluidic chip is peeled
so in the last image you can see the
design of the microfluidic chips and the
channel
in case of soft lithography the process
is quite simple and i would like to
share one step protocol which we use in
a lab
design circular micro micro channels and
chambers
the protocol goes when the protocol
describes
using agar rose powder which is readily
available which you can mix with water
and allow it to boil
we then cut the tape of syringe
desperate this agarose powder and allow
it to cool
once full with the black jar push the
agarose out from the syringe to
cylindrical agarose shape cut the
agarose into desired height and pass
copper wire through the upper cylinder
then we place this entire setup into a
box and you just add pdms into it
you keep the entire setup at 70 degrees
for 3 hours which is the curing process
and later once pdms is solidified you
just remove
the chip and boil it in water the
agarose will melt off
and you can simply pull off the wire
having circular channels and chambers
and this can be used to culture culture
cells i mean
so there are certain parameters which
needs to optimize for successful cell
culture
and these parameters are first is the
flow rate
so fluorite can can be set using syringe
pump or parasitic pumps
usually fluorides can be said to mimic
actual flow condition in blood vessels
and capillaries which range from 1 to
2 000 microliters per minute second is
the temperature and co2 control
cells require physiological temperature
and co2 control therefore
you can use a pid controller with
heating plate coupled with co2
controller
or there is also an automated onstage
incubator with co2 systems
which are available which can be mounted
on microscope to perform light cell
imaging
and lastly we also need
to monitor the cells for which you can
use inverted microscope or even
microscope so using these techniques
we attempted to culture cells in a 2d
platform
in the first image you can see the
microscopic chip
which was fabricated using
photolithography the chip consists of
inlets and outlets
which are interconnected to small
chambers which are 100 micron
in height and 3 mm in diameter
media containing dmu and f12
supplemented with 10
fbs was used for the experiments and we
selected mdmb
231 cells for our study after the chip
was fabricated
the chip was coated with polyalycin and
fiber netting to allow
cells to adhere then mdmb231 cells were
inoculated in the channel and allowed to
integrate
intubate for two to four hours this is
crucial
since cells need some time to substrate
and we cannot immediately start the flow
rate
after two to four hours challenge with
the media
is placed in the pump and at a set added
at a desired flow rate and connected to
the chip
uh we need to take care not to
uh not to set the flow rate too high
because
that would end up leading formation of
bubbles
which is a major challenge in
microfluidic 2d and 3d cell culture
systems
further we incubate the system at 37
degrees celsius with 5
co2 we monitored the cells by recording
time-lapse imaging of the cells after
every 3 minutes for 12 hours
at different flow rates and i have a
sample video
which shows the migration of the cells
the flow rate was 3 microliters per
minute and from our data we came to a
conclusion that fluorite has negligible
effects on cell migration
uh in this time lapse it is seen that
cells are growing in flow condition but
are not affected by flow rate
rather we can also see some cells which
are migrating in the opposite direction
of the flow
uh also it was noted that cell
proliferation was much slower
although these findings are still under
investigation but our initial proof of
concept
further we also found that cells do tend
to adhere to the side walls of the
microfluidic chip as compared to the
central region
this is probably due to low pressure at
the side walls as compared to the
central region
and also due to high surface roughness
at the edges which provide better
contact points for the cell
another recent investigation which we
are working on is testing of different
drug-loaded nanoparticles on cancer
cells
in our finding post-6r treatment
cellular death and cell shrinking was
observed
but strikingly after 12 hours uh
we do observe some cells trying to
re-establish and polypheny
which might be useful to explore drug
resistance and
uneven diffusion of drug and continuous
flow
this might help develop better drug
molecules to treat cancer
although these studies look simpler
there are several challenges which are
encountered in microfluidic system
the major being controlling evaporation
rate and generation of bubbles
so in the image c you can see that you
usually end up having these bubbles in
the microfluidics
chips which is a major challenge but
overall if these problems are taken care
it's easy to establish a 2d or a 3d
cell culture system now when we come to
3d environment
everything changes so 3d tumor models
are most ideal
to study cancer abnormal growth of cells
lead to tumor formation
and you know tumor comprises of several
cells in clusters and this makes it
challenging to work with
so as in the schematic tumor cell
experience non-uniform exposure to
nutrients and oxygen
there is difference in proliferation
gradient along with altered cell
signaling
also exposure to drug is limited because
most of the cells are on the surface and
this
and the cells at the core of the tumor
do not get exposed to the drug molecules
but but technically this is what is in
real condition right
so how do we develop tumor models in
continuous flow system
so our first step of study was to
investigate different scaffolds
which would serve as a 3d architecture
for the cells to grow
so we selected gelatin cellulose pdms
and one normal scaffold which is a
carbon based capital for a study
uh the study is still under
investigation but i would like to share
some very primary study
results so the average pore size of the
scaffold
range from five to 50 micron
which depends on the synthesis protocol
and how we make the different scaffolds
i have incorporated an image of the
scaffolds
and primary studies we did using a six
well plate assay
where we carried out uh different
biocompatibility studies and also empty
essay
so initially we tested the
biocompatibility and it has found that
these scaffolds are pretty
biocompatible like uh we tested the
studies on nih
and mdmv231 further these scaffolds or
was incorporated into microfluidic chip
which was designed in such a way
which would hold the scaffolds in the
cell culture chamber
so the chip comprises of inlet and
outlet
with a single large chamber and this
chamber was somewhere around
40 mm by 10 mm in this the scaffolds was
placed prior to bonding with the glass
slides
then the medium inlet was connected and
using the same protocol they said
earlier we were able to culture cells on
these scaffolds
in the following image you can see
that we have this experimental setup
where you connect
the media to the chip but uh this entire
setup is usually
uh on an onstage incubator uh
under the microscope or also uh you can
place this entire setup
in in a co2 incubator so one of the
technical
uh problems which we were facing during
our studies was
that when we stain the scaffolds we
usually
end up with a dye which remains back
in the scaffold and it is very difficult
to image them so as you can see we when
we tried using gelatin
and pdms scaffold we were able to see
cells
growing in voids of the scaffolds and
establish small
tumor-like structures nevertheless
we were able to establish the these uh
cells in the scaffolds uh we also
observed similar results when we used uh
pdms scaffolds and also cellular
scaffolds
as you can see that we have uh these
tumors tumor spheroids which are growing
on these cellular scaffolds after three
days
of incubation uh lastly
uh the the scaffold which we are right
now we have which we are working on
is the carbon-based scaffold and in the
first image you can see that you know it
it has an interwoven network of these
fibers along
and we try we tried growing cells in
these fibers
and we were pretty successful in growing
cells
up to 14 days as you can see in the
image
we we ended up with a tumor mass of
cells ranging from
100 to 200 microns in diameter uh at
present we are working to characterize
the scaffold and tumor bodies uh
and i have not included the data in the
presentation
so to summarize microfluidic cell
culture
microchip was successfully fabricated
using photolithography
a simpler method for fabricating was
explored using soft lithography we did
not saw any influence of flow rate on
cell migration
cells prefer to grow in the region of
low pressure along the side walls of the
chip
in the 2d microfluidic chip and 3d cell
culture was established in continuous
flow
by incorporating different biocompatible
scaffold
lastly we were successfully able to
culture
cells up to 14 days which eventually
turned out to be
tumor which eventually turned out to be
human tumor cells
i would like to acknowledge my mentors
dr shekhar bhansali for providing me the
opportunity to work
in his lab dr dhanajar buddhist and dr
kishov aknikor for his excellent
mentoring and support during my phd
it eventually made me independent
researcher my colleagues and friend
dr nathalia and dr el naz for their
scientific inputs and help
for this work and lastly isabella and
dennis
who are working with me on this project
and we are exploring
new possibilities every day
thank you and you can reach me out on
these contact listed
any questions
dr kamat thank you for your presentation
okay so let's get started with our q a
just a quick reminder to our audience on
how to submit questions
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
as a reminder any questions that we are
unable to get to today
dr kamat will be answering them via
email so don't worry if we don't get to
your question right away
okay let's see our first question is
why not use serum free medium culture
conditions
hello yeah can you repeat the question
absolutely our valerie
is asking why not use serum free
medium culture condition okay yeah
so basically like when we started doing
the studies like
i never tested with serum free media
because
usually uh the thing is
when culturing cells in these kind of
microfluidic devices
i usually end up with a less cell
viability if i start using
a media free of serum so usually media
supplemented with 10
fps is the most ideal condition
and in that kind of a condition we
usually get cells
proliferating in much better way rather
than using
the media free of serum
thank you now we have a question coming
in from the university of michigan
what is the size of organoid when you
finished
14 days scaffold culture
yeah uh so after 14 days of
after 14 days of the culture when we
measured the size of the scaffold
when the measured when we measure the
size of the organize uh we were able to
get
somewhere around 80 to 150 micron size
scaffold organized um
so that was
thank it here's our next question when
performing
cell migration studies what was the
seeding density of cells
in the chip and how did the flow rate
how was the flow rate
optimized for the study okay
um so when performing the migration
study we basically
exceeded 10 raised to four cells in the
microproduct chip
and to optimize the flow rate
uh basically we started from three
microliters per minute and went up till
100 microliters per minute which is the
which is similar to the
flow rate observed in our trees and
veins and
so in that in that way we were able to
see the cells migrating
um um in against the flow rate also
and that was that was the condition how
we set up the
experiment
dr kamat do you have experience with co
cultures of cells
um we haven't tried co-culturing cells
yet
uh but soon i'll be working on
a co-culture system with uh astrocytes
and neural cells
um using the same pdms or
the carbon based scaffold
we have another question coming in here
uh
you mentioned the scaffold had an
approximate pore size of 50 um
however some of the steroids you
observed were
100 um in diameter does this suggest
that the scaffold was flexible enough to
stretch
allowing a larger steroid
so um in the initial studies
uh a microscopic studies which i have
observed
although the pore size of the is smaller
usually the cells uh tends to cling on
these
uh scaffolds or these grooves and
usually we see
at some points that the scaffold is
flexible in case of pdms we did observe
the scaffold to be quite flexible and
cells uh
um growing within the scaffolds and then
they
we also see some of the cells growing
outside the scaffold making a larger
steroid kind of a structure so yes the
scaffolds are
flexible but that also depends on type
of the scaffold so we did not saw that
in case of carbon based scaffold but in
bdms
scaffold we did see that the scaffold is
quite flexible and
we usually get up with large spheroids
thanks for that question jeffrey and we
actually have another one from him we're
gonna go on to this one
did you observe significant non-specific
cell binding to the tubing interface to
the pdms
chip uh yeah that's a good question
actually yeah
so it usually ends up that we we do see
a lot of cells which bind to the tubing
but not a significant amount of cell but
yes uh cells too
uh tend to adhere to this tubing as well
as to the
channels the inlet channels specifically
at the inlets and the outlets
so uh if if to give a
estimate around five to ten percent of
cells uh seeded cells we usually end up
into the tubings and into the inlets and
the outlets of the chip
thank you dr kamat and here we have
another question
have you investigated the effect of
different culture media
on the growth and metabolism of cancer
cells grown ex
vivo uh no not really actually uh i have
not tested different
type of medias yet uh on the cancer cell
but
um in one of my previous studies we do
observe change in morphologies
uh when we use different kind of media
in continuous flow cultures
but i haven't used i haven't done a
complete study
using different type of medias yet
okay and our next question coming in
here we have so many great questions
coming in as a reminder to our audience
those questions that
dr khamad is unable to answer today due
to time constraints
he will be answering them via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration all right
let's go on to our next question
how do you make a 3d structure in a
microfluidic device
okay um so uh
basically like we are
basically making these scaffolds which
are
of this three dimension and then
incorporating them in the microfluidic
device
so there are several protocols which in
which uh the device
itself uh the scaffolds are inside the
device
but before binding it to the glass
we do incorporate these scaffolds into
the microfluidic device so basically we
are not
um making the structure in the device
structures are
made uh separately and then incorporated
in the device
by bonding it or by plasma bonding it or
by other methods
um so in case of pdms usually we make
these uh porous scaffolds
and then we incorporate it in in these
smaller devices
and then we carry out the cell culture
study so it's kind of easy
in a way that uh we can later on just
um open up these devices and remove the
scaffold so we get a
we get the entire structure intact but
with cells which are growing on the
scaffold
so it's quite easy to extract the
scaffold from the devices
and that's how we work right
thank you dr now what are the chances of
contamination
and other troubleshooting oh
yeah actually you know that's that's a
good question so yeah
we usually end up with the chances of
contamination is
uh it depends on on the handling and
also
on the conditions uh usually
um you won't get a contamination
unless uh you have properties properly
sterilize the media
uh the microscopic chip and other other
you know devices and tubings and
everything but
uh usually if uh
the tubings and the connectors are not
uh taken care of then we usually end up
with contamination
and also other troubles the major
troubleshooting is
as i mentioned we usually end up with
bubbles which
which is at the major kind of issues
when using microcredit devices
and also sometimes evaporation rates so
if your flow rate is too
less you usually uh it usually
evaporates the media
or something like that and then that's
another challenge so
uh it takes a lot of time to optimize uh
these
systems but once it is optimized uh it's
really
you know it gives really good results
now let's go back to the topic of
scaffold now i have a few versions of
this question coming in
was the scaffold treated prior to the
experiment
um so what we usually do
is we treat the scaffolds with the
polyalycine for cell adherence so after
the
after the scaffolds have been prepared
we usually wash them in
70 ipa and then two or three washes with
pbs
and then try to keep the scaffold in dns
water
for at least four to six hours and after
that we
treat it with polyethylene fossil and
adherence
now dr kabat was any viability else they
performed
and if not which are the assays to
characterize the tumor body
um so actually we
did try uh to study the cells
uh under the microscope
so basically other other poly other
acids which can be performed could be
a light dead staining or you know atp
generation assay
and also um one can go for chi 67 based
acids which are this is the
proliferation marker in tumor cell
so basically fluorescent-based acids can
be carried out
uh to study cell viability and
polyphenatia
thank you doctor come on now we have
time for one more question
which drug-loaded nanoparticles were
used in the study
and how was the study carried out
so this is this is one of one of the
studies which uh i've been trying uh
in my group and basically we are making
different nanoparticles
which are natural natural polymers using
kyto san
or alginate nanoparticles and what we do
is we synthesize these nanoparticles in
the range of
100 to 150 nanometers which are
encapsulated
with the anti-cancer drug such as
doxorubicin or lactotexan and then we
try to study
the effect of these
nano drugs on cancer cells in continuous
flow and
culture uh so basically uh using these
nanoparticles to study
how the cellular uptake or how does uh
the activity
drug activity uh and interaction with
the stealth takes place
in a continuous flow kind of a culture
thank you dr now do you have any final
comments for our audience
um so um yeah i mean um
uh this field is quite challenging and
interesting and
uh it's uh we can do a lot of studies
using microfluidic cell culture system
um traditionally if it's possible in
near future to translate
all the in-vitro studies to microfluidic
systems it would be really great and
would give us a
great depth of understanding in studying
these
cellular micro environment and cellular
interaction
at a more dynamic level rather than
using the traditional in-vitro
assay so thank you everyone
i would like to once again thank dr
vivit come up for his time today
and for his important contribution to
cell culture research
i would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's
educational webcast now before we go i'd
like to thank all of you for joining us
today
and for your great questions again
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand laborats will
alert you via email
when it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
you will now be redirected to the
registration page for our upcoming
webinar on choroid plexus epithelial
cell
2d and modified 3d cell culture models
presented by our next cell culture hero
dr elizabeth delary
dr dillary will be presenting live on
july 31st at 9 a.m pacific time
we hope to see you there bye for now and
have a great day